[Applause]
[Music]
it's a glorious wednesday or as cat
calls it two days from vodka
hi kid she's never gone two days without
vodka
before we get to the news however it is
time for
greg seven jokes
president biden has cancelled
trick-or-treating at the white house for
halloween when asked why joe responded
children wearing costumes and going
house to house for candy trivializes the
very thing we are celebrating the birth
of jesus
comedian
kathy griffin posted a video of her
shaking her breasts from a balcony in
los angeles authorities report it's the
first time they've seen migrants turn
around at the border and head home
we don't need a wall
california governor gavin newsom has
mandated coveted vaccines for all state
employees but less than two-thirds have
complied can't fault them in san
francisco for some reason there's a
shortage of needles
sportscaster joe buck claims he wants
peed in a bottle while calling an nfl
touchdown big deal i once peed in a
bottle on the five while doing an
animals or great segment
then i told kill me it was gatorade
[Laughter]
he didn't mind at all
a minnesota surgeon was fired for
telling a school board to let parents
make decisions about masking kids which
makes total sense i mean what does a
surgeon know about masks
a sexist would say a sexist would say
that didn't even get a laugh tyrus
what's with this crowd
some new york schools are banning any
halloween costumes based on the netflix
show squid game which depicts mass
murder in a related story stores are
pulling all their witch's costumes
because the hosts on the view consider
it cultural appropriation
note to self make all jokes about the
view
a hiker lost for 24 hours ignored calls
from rescuers because they came from an
unknown number even worse he was in a
bed bath and beyond
and that was my seven jokes
all right
so america get ready for more crime i'm
so excited we should all stand up and do
the wave except this is a crime wave so
when we sit back down our wallets will
be gone
last night i went to dinner and you know
what i didn't get
murdered
that's quite a feat when you consider i
had the jalapeno poppers at the time
square applebee's
so as you can tell i'm not dead
but
but for how long last night we told you
about biden's 42-page plan to promote
gender equity that's one page for every
gender
inside the plan is a proposal to
eliminate cash bail for suspects and not
just the ones with the initials hb
now this happens as freed repeat
offenders have been killing and injuring
people thanks to this new policy it's
turning repeat offenders into repeat
repeat repeat offenders
it's like binge watching will and grace
we've heard the examples in virginia a
man beats up his spouse gets released on
no cash bail and then he kills her
the many attacks here on women some
resulting in death all done by thugs
who've been arrested and then released
somehow that effect on women wasn't in
the 42-page plan on gender equity
the radical da's behind this don't seem
to mind maybe because it's working out
the way that they want it to nothing
shall slow the revolution including
murder you gotta break a few eggs to
make an omelet and instead of eggshells
that's gun shells and the media is there
to help out every time we mention the
homicide rates what do you hear
that other violent crime has gone down
take the la times reporting that
california had a 31
jump in homicides but they point out
that the state's faring better on other
violent crime well that's good to know
it's good to know that when someone
attacks you they're going to finish the
job
meanwhile san francisco families are
hiring private security to keep them
safe so i'm curious how wealthy are
these families since they can afford
this and more importantly did they vote
democrat because clearly they can afford
that too
if you're living in sf and instead of
moving you just hire private guards you
must be doing all right and you're doing
so well you can avoid the hell that
harms other people
that's the kind of privatization wealthy
liberals love
vote to defund the police for you then
hire private police to protect
themselves
maybe it's time to introduce bills that
ban private security by democrats i mean
if they can throw no cash bail at us
can't we throw that right back at them
if you support no cash bail why should
you live in safety if the rest of us
can't it's a direct result of your
stupid destructive decisions like
slashing police budgets or putting pop
rocks in cat's vape pen
but you see the pattern dems get into
power to exempt themselves from the laws
they force on others as long as they're
in power they can dance masculists in
public and eat in a fancy restaurant
while you're under house arrest
some can even marry their brother
that must have been a cozy wedding when
they asked guests if they were relatives
of the bride or groom
they all just said yes
talk about dysfunctional as minneapolis
gets worse and worse mentally ill han
calls
the cops dysfunctional
but omar calling anyone dysfunctional is
like me calling anyone drop dead
gorgeous i mean talk about the pot
calling the kettle black you know what
i'm saying or in this case the wife
calling the brother husband
but these libs are all safe and secure
meanwhile a grandmother must take two
extra buses to find a walgreens since
they all closed in her neighborhood due
to the retail theft sanctioned by
liberal leaders
now we wish the democrat party might
rediscover common sense but they won't
they won
now they see their experiment in action
burnt out cities record homicide rates
looting as recreational behavior rapes
in schools covered up by flax it's not
exactly a brochure for sandals resorts
and those pushing it demand even more
you know you could say they're a glutton
for punishment except they're not
getting punished you are
[Applause]
tonight yes
he left the democratic party in the 80s
and it's the only time he ever left a
party in the 80s
former director of the national economic
council and host of kudlow on fox
business larry kudlow
she's so sharp she carves pumpkins with
her thoughts contributor to the
spectator
hey
if she wants a scary costume she can
just take her hair extensions out watch
this contributor catch him
and he's stronger than a hippies b.o
after running the miami marathon my
massive sidekick and the nwa's world
television champion iris
so larry i want you to know that despite
my terrible choice in socks i wore
pinstripes for you looking good yeah
really good yeah i like to think of
myself as a larry kudlow jr you've
picked up your whole game i have picked
up my game cause you know what we're
winning and that's when you pick it up
you know what i'm saying yes so am i
missing something why double down on
some kind of policy that everyone can
see is killing people i mean no one can
deny that this is bad policy what's the
underlying thing i just think that the
far left democratic party the
progressives hate cops yeah and want to
do everything they can
not to help cops right and
no bail no cash bail no any bill it's a
revolving door it's about recidivism i
thought your opening was exactly right
and
we have it here in new york it's just
awful you talk to almost anybody in law
enforcement
they want to repost bail keep them in at
least keep them locked up for a while
and i just want to go maybe one step
further
i want to end sanctuary cities
i think they've been hiding
uh illegal immigrants who are committing
crimes constantly recidivism and illegal
immigrants is a terrible plague people
have been killed time and time again
they will not report it to the federal
cops to the fbi and i think that's a
catastrophe and i think that should be
changed in fact i want no sanctuary
cities throughout the country at all i
would be okay with sanctuary cities if
they were sanctuaries for things i like
to do
right
yes you know what i'm saying yes yeah i
mean it's like okay so if you can have a
sanctuary city for illegal aliens what
about other illegal activities that i
like to participate in then we could
talk sanctuary cities
right
thanks
you notice
kate i've not said what my illegal
activity is good job very smart thank
you very very exactly and i'm not ever
going to say what it is
maybe call me anyway
could the equity part of this whole idea
be that to
like raise the murder rate of women so
it's equal to men is that what this is
about you have it exactly right it's a
it's a quality of insecurity that's
that's the equity that we're going for
because if we can't have safety across
the board we're going to make everyone
safe if you're not going to be safe in a
city
you can't be safe in the suburbs and
what you were talking about with with
san francisco is really interesting i
actually heard that the cast of fuller
house is now equipped with ar-15s really
yeah but but it's really sad what's
happening in the cities it's what the
democrats do across the board if there's
something bad you just have to make it
bad for everyone and unfortunately
really the best solution you said that
they were hiring uh security yeah and
whatnot but the best solution i think is
actually to get out of san francisco up
and moved to florida yeah texas anywhere
else other than than yeah the only
problem is they often bring their bad
ideas with them you know
the lady over there tyrus makes a good
point
she says that when things are bad the
democrat's solution is to make it bad
for everybody rather than like fix the
bad i think that's a very coaching point
by that lady sitting over there you
forgot a name again didn't you no her
name is kate kate very good but she's a
lady yeah
the only good point i've ever made thank
you not true you know
i think
we we're kind of being a little too
tough on the democrats i mean attempted
murder is down greg
it's way down you know what's funny it's
down yeah but it got because they
murdered yeah yeah yeah but you can't
have both they're seeing it through yeah
there's nothing worse than someone
trying to kill you and you call the
police and the police come get him and
he's going away for a long time ma'am
don't you worry and your son's like yeah
bye bad guy
17 minutes later
oh no he has a key
and then the murder happens like that's
literally
what america is looking at now that's
what happened in virginia
and everyone and then they're like well
because
their definition of
equality has nothing to do with equality
because if america is really about
equality of opportunity it's not
everyone's equal because yeah i'm not
equal with a pedophile i'm not equal
with a man who beats his wife every
night i'm not yeah so when they try to
say everything's that's their whole plan
i think
a good the next whoever's running on the
republican party
i'd wait i wouldn't say anything now but
try this
let's stop it doesn't matter your sexual
orientation your gender the color of
your skin let's start
we're focusing on people's character
yeah because character is the only thing
you can count on yeah no definitely
absolutely you know kat i bet uh no cash
bail
would have been a great thing when you
were dating
yeah it would have saved me a lot of
money no it would have and then get then
all of a sudden so you go and you get
married and what do they do they get rid
of no cash bail totally screwing you on
it's almost like it's a personal affront
to me
now that i'm no longer dating convicts
and married to a wonderful man
yeah we don't have to hear that whole do
i pay rent or bail him out
if i paid the rent you know if i didn't
neither of us would have a place to live
yes
it took months to get rid of that guy
he's always breaking his foot
tough from the couch to the fridge oh
yeah
uh anything anything else
i don't like i want to be safe i do i'm
very
i don't want to give anybody any ideas
but i am very murderable yeah yes that's
true i i mean look at me like i'm also
like not allowed to have a gun so what i
can do someone tries to kill me i can
just go i no
yeah that's it yeah that's it and
i don't think that's quite a match for a
murderer but no no no can i can i just
go back to it ty i love tires i know you
do i mean i'm afraid of him but i love
him
you know he's he's got his champions
belt on yes really tough for me but i'm
glad there's a lot of distance but
equality of opportunity yes equality
look uh you mentioned how the
billionaires have their own security and
you know i admit that there's some
hypocrisy there
but greg i want to be here to defend
billionaires
basically want to help them out yeah i
think they take too much flack
billionaires do wonderful things they
create businesses tens of millions of
jobs higher wages more family income and
i think they need support they need
support groups people like myself have
to stand up and support them and the
reason i said equality of opportunity is
these lefty democrats want to punish
success right and i don't i want to
reward success unless you're a
successful criminal that's the american
dream unless i'm a successful criminal
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else